(emergency sirens)
- [Johnny] On a spring day, 10 years ago,
a 41 year old Australian man
named Julian Assange dressed up
as a motorcycle delivery man.
He dyed his hair, put
colored contacts in his eyes,
and even put a rock in his shoe
so that he would walk
differently than normal.
He was sure he was being followed
by dark government forces
that were attempting to capture him
and send him to the United
States to be locked up.
He showed up here to
the Embassy of Ecuador
in Central London.
Once inside this embassy,
he wouldn't be on British soil anymore.
No one could barge in here and grab him.
He'd be safe.
It's called political asylum.
Oh, and by the way,
this isn't actual footage
of Julian Assange in 2012.
- [Director] Action.
- [Crew] You look great.
- This is an actor.
We did a reenactment of this whole thing.
Anyway.
(suspenseful music)
Assange did make it inside that day.
And after entering the
Ecuadorian Embassy in London,
he wouldn't leave it for seven years.
Testing one, two, three,
I've been looking at a lot of this.
I've actually started hanging
up the documents over here
because they've been
taking up too much space.
I want to tell you the
story of Julian Assange.
- [Man] This guy's a traitor.
- [Man] Saddle up WikiLeaks.
- [Hillary] This is a blow to transparency
and a blow to a free press.
- What this story is,
is like an expression
of a new kind of power,
the power of secrets, of information.
- An anti-war online organization
attacking US policy in Afghanistan.
- And the reason I'm calling
what Julian Assange does power
is because the US is trying
to lock him up for 175 years
because of what he did.
It's all here in this indictment.
The most powerful country in
the world feels threatened
by this man and what he's done.
I want to take you through
Julian Assange's story,
and then to unpack why the United States
is trying to lock him up
for the rest of his life.
And I want to persuade you
that no matter what you think
of Julian Assange and his
conduct and his ethics
and his mission, this case
should not be ignored.
(upbeat music)
- Illegally shoot the son of a (beep).
- [Woman] Get Assange to
Sweden and hang on to him.
- [Man] Crazy Horse 187, we
have 5 distinct individuals
with AK-47s.
- Never know what the outcome is,
but the truth is always
the best place to start.
(gunfire erupts)
- Okay wait, before we
dive into this video,
I want to thank today's
sponsor because the sponsors
are the people who make
these videos possible.
They allow me to do this as my job.
Thank you. NordVPN for
sponsoring today's video.
If you don't know what a VPN is,
it's kind of just like an
all around protective tool
that you don't actually see
or interact with very much.
It works in the background.
A VPN allows you to
connect to the internet,
but via a different country
so that you can encrypt
and protect your connection,
but also, so that you can access things
that you might not be able
to access in your country.
An example is entertainment.
Like there are things
available in the UK on Netflix
that are not available here
in the US, but with a VPN,
I can connect and get access
to all of that content.
Also, it works the other way.
I'm traveling a lot more lately.
And when I'm in a different country,
my computer and all the things
I'm logged into kind of freak
out, 'cause I think I'm like
a hacker from somewhere else.
So, I connect to a server
in the United States
and my internet thinks
I'm in the United States
and they don't kick me
out of like my Gmail.
It's not complicated to connect.
You don't have to be like technical
or like understand how it works.
You just press a button
and you're connected.
Oh, and recently Nord VPN
is not just a VPN anymore.
They had this whole new
threat protection system.
It blocks malware.
It blocks trackers.
It blocks malicious ads.
It allows you to surf the
internet much more safely.
This is a very affordable tool.
And if you want to get in on it,
do us both a favor and go
to Nordvpn.com/JohnnyHarris,
where you can get an exclusive deal
to get a great deal on a VPN.
Oh, and the best part
is if you don't like it,
or if it's not useful to you,
you can get your money
back within 30 days.
So go check it out, go see
if it works for your life,
makes your life better.
Nordvpn.com/JohnnyHarris.
Thank you, Nord VPN for
supporting the videos that I do.
I really appreciate it.
Now let's get back into the story.
Okay, let's get up to speed really quickly
on who this guy even is
and how he ended up trapped
in an embassy in London.
Julian Assange is an Australian hacker
who spent most of his life
breaking into computers
and getting his hands on information
that he wasn't supposed to see,
but that he believed the world should see.
When he was 35, he built a website
where whistle blowers of all kinds
could upload sensitive information
that he, Julian Assange,
on his new website would publish.
And the upside of all of this
was that these whistle blowers
would remain totally anonymous.
He claimed that even he wouldn't
know who his sources were.
So that was 2006.
Julian Assange builds WikiLeaks.
And soon after, he starts
receiving submissions,
like people start giving him
documents that are supposed
to be secret.
And he starts publishing them.
Everything from drone strikes in Yemen
to oil scandals in Peru to
corruption in the Arab world,
Tibetan uprisings in China.
Leaks like this sort of
seem common to us now,
but this was like 2007.
WikiLeaks was a totally new thing.
It was this open source
intelligence website acting
in the name of no
government with no location.
But with this very idealistic vision
of making the world's
information, totally transparent,
exposing corruption,
exposing government secrets.
- Understand how far
you can push government
into doing something that is
just by exposing injustice.
- But WikiLeaks wasn't
really noticed until 2010,
when something happened that
would change everything.
(suspenseful music)
In Iraq, there was a 22 year old
American Intelligence Analyst
named Chelsea Manning.
Horrified by what she
was seeing, she decided
to download hundreds of
thousands of classified documents
from military computers
and upload them directly to WikiLeaks.
(suspenseful music continues)
- Of course our top story
this morning, the White House
blasting the release of over
90,000 US military records.
- It was the biggest leak in history.
And this is the stuff
we've been looking through
over the past few weeks.
Hundreds of thousands of
classified documents containing
never before seen details on
how the US conducts its war,
its diplomacy, its intelligence.
I mean, let me show
you some of this stuff.
Now let me just do a
quick disclaimer here,
going through these leaks,
there is a lot of like
horrific stuff like,
stuff I just don't even
want to talk about here.
I'll go over it kind of in vague terms
and let you go read the rest.
But war is horrible.
And what these documents reveal
is like a detailed version of that.
- My fellow citizens, at this hour,
American and coalition forces
are in the early stages
of military operations
to disarm Iraq, to free its people,
and to defend the world from grave danger.
- In these leaks, we
learn about secret raids.
We read about scenes
of US military people,
executing Iraqi families.
We also get a lot of data.
The US military claimed
that it wasn't keeping
track of deaths in Iraq,
but these leaks showed
that they actually were.
And that the number of casualties,
including civilian deaths
was actually way higher
than anyone thought before.
The leaks also revealed
this classified footage
that again, I'm not
gonna show all of it here
or even the worst parts.
- [Soldier] There's more
that keep walking by
and one of them has a weapon.
- [Dispatch] Relevant, copy that one six.
- [Soldier] That's a weapon.
- [Johnny] It shows a US helicopter firing
on a group of Iraqis, who
they thought were insurgents,
but was really just a family,
including children walking
with two Reuters journalists.
- [Soldier] (beep) prick.
- [Crazy Horse 1-8] Hotel two six,
this is Crazy Horse one eight.
- [Johnny] They were
carrying cameras, not guns.
- [Soldier] Request permission to engage.
- [Soldier] C'mon let us shoot.
- [Johnny] And yet in this video,
you see them open fire on these people.
- [Dispatch] So, uh, you
are free to engage, over.
- [Man] Let me know when you got 'em.
- [Soldier] Let's shoot.
- [Man] Light 'em all up.
- [Soldier] Come on, fire.
(rapid gunfire erupts)
- [Soldier] Oh yeah, look
at those dead bastards.
- [Soldier] Nice.
- [Soldier] Well it's their
fault for bringing their kids
to a battle.
- [Soldier] That's right.
- You read about this scene
where an Apache helicopter
is flying over some insurgents in a house
who are surrendering, they're
coming out of their house
with their hands up.
And yet the Apache
helicopter gets the clearance
to fire on them.
And their justification is
according to this leaked log,
you're not allowed to
surrender to aircraft.
They're still valid targets.
I mean, it's horrendous.
As a journalist, I'm
skeptical, I'm like, okay,
these are like two or three bad apples
is this what we're staring at?
But no, through these leaks,
you see that 15,000 civilians
were killed in previously
unknown incidents.
15,000!
These documents reveal a
culture and a system of abuse
and torture in Iraq, mostly
by the Iraqi military
and army that the US military knew about,
but did nothing to solve.
And the only reason why
we know about it now
is because Chelsea Manning gave WikiLeaks
all of these documents.
There's one Department of
State leak from the Embassy
in Belgium that shows that the
US tried to pressure Belgium
into taking some of the
prisoners from Guantanamo Bay
in order to curry favor with the US.
you see the US being like, hey Belgium,
take some of these Guantanamo prisoners.
It's a low cost way for
Belgium to attain prominence
in Europe, like it's backroom deals
exchanging Guantanamo
prisoners for political favors.
We would've not known any of this
had these leaks not come out.
All of this turned out
to be a very grim insight
into how the US is conducting its wars
and unsurprisingly, after these
giant leaks came out in 2010
and 2011 on WikiLeaks,
the Pentagon was furious.
- This was dumped on us.
Like it was dumped on
you all Sunday night.
- It is the role of good journalism
to take on powerful abuses.
And when powerful abuses are taken on,
there is always a back reaction.
- Julian Assange's website had gone
from being a small hacker
website with some leaks
to something that now
had worldwide attention.
- This isn't a WikiLeak.
This is a Wiki torrent.
- [Reporter] These
documents have generated
a mix of reactions from
horrified to appalled.
- [Johnny] And Assange,
himself, became the public face
for this and he became really polarizing.
He was either praised as
a courageous journalist.
- The role that Julian Assange has played
in exposing uncomfortable
truths is something
that he should be very proud of.
- WikiLeaks is no different
from the New York Times.
- He just believes in
justice, believes in honesty,
believes in exposing governments.
- Or he was reproached
and condemned as a villain
who was set on damaging
the US security interest
and putting people in
danger in the process.
- I hope he rots in
hell, starting with that.
- This guy's a traitor, a treasonist
and he has broken every
law of the United States.
Illegally shoot the son of a (beep).
- But regardless of what the
public thought about him,
the reality is the US government
now felt like they were
at war with Julian Assange and WikiLeaks.
- The United States strongly
condemns the illegal disclosure
of classified information.
There have been examples in history
in which official conduct
has been made public
in the name of exposing
wrongdoings or misdeeds.
This is not one of those cases.
- And the next chapter of his
life would be spent trying
to avoid being sent to
the US to face them.
And this is why Julian Assange went
to the Ecuadorian Embassy in London.
Okay, so after this huge
leak, it's now like 2012.
Assange is living in London
and he's actually facing the possibility
of being sent to Sweden
to face an investigation
into sexual misconduct allegations.
And even though this Sweden
investigation legally
has nothing to do with
the big leaking thing
that he had done, Assange
was convinced that the UK
and Sweden were working with the US to try
to get Assange back onto
US soil to face trial.
So instead of go and participate
in the investigation,
he fled to seek political
asylum inside the walls
of this embassy,
(upbeat music)
An embassy is kind of
like a little enclave
within a country.
Like, this is a little slice
of Ecuador within London.
So the UK couldn't do anything.
They couldn't go storm into an embassy.
So instead they just
positioned a ton of police
outside of the embassy.
And this is the moment, this
spectacle of all these police
sitting outside of the embassy,
where you realize that
this is a huge deal.
On paper, this was actually
a really small deal.
The US wanted to arrest
Assange to send him to Sweden,
to face this sexual
misconduct investigation.
But all of this shows us
that this is not about a
small investigation in Sweden.
The US wanted Assange to
punish him for what he did
and the UK, it was looking
like was ready to help them.
So while Assange is in
the walls of this embassy,
he's protected and the US
would have to wait him out,
building their case, but
wait a minute, hold on.
What exactly are we
charging Assange with here?
He published a bunch of leaked documents.
So what's the crime here.
And honestly that is
the heart of this story.
What crime did he commit?
I'm gonna get there.
I want to just finish the
story of what happens next.
Julian Assange is in an embassy in London,
the weeks turn into months and
the months turn into years.
And Julian Assange is living
in an embassy, not leaving.
He occasionally comes
out onto this balcony
to deliver a speech to his
increasingly large support base.
(crowd cheering)
- Can you hear me?
- [Crowd] Yeah!
- But like this guy is
confined to the embassy.
- Right, I joked it's a
little bit like living
in a space station because
there's no natural light
and there's, you've gotta
make all your own stuff
and you can't go out to shops and so on.
- From the embassy, Assange
continues to run WikiLeaks.
He publishes troves of secret documents.
It is from the embassy
that he declares his
hate for Hillary Clinton.
- The American liberal press
in falling over themselves
to defend Hillary Clinton,
are erecting a demon
that is going to put nooses
around everyone's necks.
- And it is here that
he orchestrates a plan
to damage her campaign by
strategically publishing emails
that were stolen from the Democratic Party
and from Clinton's Campaign
Chair, John Podesta,
WikiLeaks posted these
emails in daily batches
throughout October 2016 a
month before the election.
Soon, mounting evidence
showed that WikiLeaks
got these emails, potentially unknowingly,
from a Russian government
agent who, like Assange,
was trying to damage the Clinton Campaign.
The leaked emails helped
the Trump Campaign
and quickly made Assange an
enemy of American progressives
who had tended to support
Assange and WikiLeaks
because they were keeping the government
and the military accountable,
but now they hated them.
- WikiLeaks, I love WikiLeaks.
- So now it's 2017 and Trump is President.
- This WikiLeaks is unbelievable.
- Assange is still in the embassy
and from the embassy,
Assange and WikiLeaks
drop another huge leak.
This time of CIA documents.
It revealed the playbook of the CIA's
cyber warfare strategy.
Releasing all of these
documents had one major result,
making all of the CIA's
tools completely worthless.
Trump who had praised WikiLeaks
for like helping him get
elected now hated WikiLeaks.
- I know nothing about WikiLeaks.
It's not my thing.
- WikiLeaks walks like a
hostile intelligence service
and talks like a hostile
intelligence service.
- So by 2019, Julian Assange
is still in the embassy
and now he's pissed off everyone
for one reason or another.
It's at this time that the
Trump administration starts
to really get serious about
how do we get this guy
and how do we punish him
severely for what he's done.
They start upping the ante on their case
against Julian Assange.
But Assange starts to get
really restless in the embassy.
I mean, can you blame him?
It's been like seven years.
He starts to mistrust his host.
And in turn, his host,
the Ecuadorian diplomats
are getting kind of tired of him.
His poor hygiene, his
habit of playing football
in the hallways.
Meanwhile, Ecuador's new
president is like less sympathetic
to WikiLeaks because he
was actually the subject
of some embarrassing leaks himself.
He actually called
Assange a miserable hacker
whose only goal is to
destabilize governments.
And so they kicked him out.
- The British Police
were seemingly invited
into this very small embassy.
- [Johnny] Seven years after he had walked
into this building, Assange finally left.
- [Assange] We must resist.
- He was immediately arrested.
Again on paper, the UK
government wanted him
because of this sexual
investigation in Sweden from 2012.
That investigation had been dropped.
And yet the UK kept him
in jail because the US
had formally requested
Assange to be extradited,
which basically means one
country asked another country
to detain and send a criminal
back to their country
to face charges.
The UK would hear and
assess the US's request
and in the meantime, Assange would sit
in the Belmarsh Prison, 45
minutes from Central London.
And that's where he is
today when I'm filming this
and he's not doing great.
He's been examined by doctors
and by the UN representative for torture.
And they've basically
concluded that Assange
has experienced severe
psychological trauma
because of his isolation in
the embassy and now in jail,
including extreme stress, chronic anxiety,
intense psychological trauma.
The British government, of
course, disagreed with this.
But the UN has said
that he has been subject
to psychological torture
and other cruel, inhumane,
or degrading treatment of punishment.
They also claim that he's
been medically neglected.
Many are calling this
retaliation, punishing Assange,
not legally, but through
these really inhumane ways
of not giving him medical treatment,
isolating him in ways
that aren't warranted.
And now is the moment where
we need to remind ourselves
why this man is in jail.
Not because he's been
charged with a crime,
but because he published
hundreds of thousands
of classified documents
that an Army Intel Analyst,
Chelsea Manning gave to him
and the US wants to punish him.
So, he's rotting in a jail
waiting for the legal process
on whether or not he's gonna
get sent back to the US
to face these charges.
And to me, this gets to
the most important part
of this story, because what happens next
affects not just Julian
Assange and his story,
but it could set a
precedent for all of us.
Those of us who do journalism
and those of us who rely
on journalism to teach us
about the world.
What I want to do next is I
wanna dive into this stuff.
I want to walk you through
these two documents,
which are basically the US's
case against Julian Assange
as laid out by the Trump
administration in 2018.
It's daunting.
It's a lot of stuff.
It's a lot of legal jargon,
but I've been through it all.
And I want to explain why this matters.
Okay, let's do this.
Oh shit.
Here we go.
Okay.
So, stick with me as I
explain the legal case
against Julian Assange and
what that means for journalism.
(inquisitive music)
The thing that the Department
of Justice focuses on
is the events of 2010
when Assange received tons of
classified cables and war logs
from Intel Analyst, Chelsea Manning,
who was previously Bradley Manning,
has transitioned to Chelsea Manning.
Manning had a security clearance,
violated that security clearance
and ended up serving seven years in prison
for leaking all of this
stuff to WikiLeaks.
It would've been 35 years if Obama
hadn't lessened her sentence.
So the US focuses on
this super giant leak.
They start out by reminding us
just how many documents were leaked.
If you add this up,
it's like over 700,000
classified documents
were leaked to the world.
And then they go into the actual crimes.
What they see as the
crimes, there's 18 counts,
basically 18 instances where
they allege he broke the law.
In total, this would be a
sentence of 175 years in prison.
Luckily we don't have to
go through all 18 counts
to understand them because
they fit pretty nicely
into three main buckets,
hacking, aiding, and publishing.
First, let's go into
hacking, the first bucket.
- [Hillary] It's about
assisting the hacking.
- This first allegation is the least scary
for Julian Assange.
It basically says that
Assange worked with Manning
to crack a password on
a government computer
so that Manning could grab
documents without being detected.
Incidentally, it didn't work.
They didn't crack the password,
but the indictment alleges
that he tried and therefore,
it is considered a conspiracy
to commit computer fraud,
which is a violation of this
like eighties era law called
the Computer Fraud Abuse Act.
It has a max sentence of five years,
which for Julian Assange
is not that big of a deal,
given that he spent seven
years in the Ecuadorian Embassy
evading the charges.
Okay, so that's the first
one, the least severe.
The other 17 counts
allege that Julian Assange
violated the Espionage Act.
- [Hillary] He has to
answer for what he has done.
- Wait, what?
The Espionage Ace, hold on.
You know I printed it off
and read through the Espionage Act.
I mean, look at that cool font.
The Espionage Act is really intense.
It was passed in 1917 when
we were fighting World War I.
I'm gonna read some of it here.
Whoever, for the purpose of
obtaining information respective
to states or to the advantage
of any foreign nation
or otherwise obtains
information, concealing defense,
(overlapping voices)
Navy yard submarine base fueling
station, torpedo station,
dockyard, canal, railroad,
arsenal, factory, mine.
Holy smokes, I could keep going.
This law was meant to punish people
who were government employees
or members of the military
who had government secrets
and went and gave them
to another nation that then
hurt the United States,
basically spies, espionage.
That's what it's about, espionage.
Chelsea Manning violated this
because she was a member of the military.
She had a security clearance.
She violated that security clearance
by using her privileged information
and therefore broke this law.
But Julian Assange is not that.
He has never worked for the US Government.
He's never had a security clearance.
He's an Australian hacker and activist.
It is very, very rare
that the Espionage Act
is used against somebody who
is not a government employee
who does not have a security clearance.
So what is going on here?
How is the US trying to
use the Espionage Act
against an Australian who
didn't leak any information.
He published information
that was leaked to him.
(upbeat music)
So bucket two, I'm
calling aiding or helping.
The US case here uses the
Espionage Act to say that, indeed,
it was Chelsea Manning who
broke the law directly.
As an Army Intel Analyst.
It was her who had access to
the secrets she leaked to them.
But in US federal law, we
have this thing that says
that if you aid someone
in committing a crime,
you are punishable,
kind of as if you've
broken the law yourself.
Yep got it right here.
Title 18 folks, Crimes
and Criminal Procedure,
Whoever commits an offense
against the United States
or aids, abets, counsel's,
commands, induces,
or procures its commission
is punishable as a principal.
If you helped out, you did it too.
So, they used this law
to say, yeah, Julian,
you didn't do the hacking and leaking,
but like you helped you aided,
abetted, counseled, induced,
or procured and willingly caused Manning
to do this because you
promised that you were going
to publish all this stuff.
So, that was sort of like
incentivizing Chelsea Manning
to do this.
And that is why you are being punished
under the Espionage Act.
Wait, this is a giant deal.
This is a big deal.
This logical chain that was just created.
Assange is being charged
with aiding Manning,
a convicted spy because
he published the things
that the spy gave to him, okay?
File that away for a second.
Let's get onto the third bucket in here.
The third bucket I'm calling publishing.
Counts 15 through 17,
and let's just read directly straight here
from the indictment.
The government says that
Assange having unauthorized
possession of all of these
reports from Afghanistan and Iraq
and the State Department,
et cetera, which again,
he had sort of induced
Manning to give to him.
They then specifically
allege that the crime here
is that having all of these documents,
he then communicated those
documents to the world
by publishing them on the internet.
Whoa, the crime is publishing.
That's the crime counts 15 through 17
are that he published something.
(suspenseful music)
Okay, we're done with the legal talk here.
Let's talk about what this means.
Back to our three buckets here.
The first one is the least scary to me.
Did Assange try to help
Manning hack a password
so that he could remain anonymous?
Maybe, the facts aren't super
robust here, but whatever,
if there is evidence for
that and he gets convicted,
that's five years in prison, okay.
It's these other two buckets
that used the Espionage Act.
Let's that Assange was aiding
Manning because he promised
to publish the documents.
And then he went further and
committed three more crimes
by actually publishing
them to all the world
on the internet.
Let me explain something
about journalism really quick,
New York Times article about
Iran, doesn't matter, whatever.
When you read the international section
or the politics section
of any big newspaper,
you will see quotes from
officials inside the government
or diplomats or whatever,
who request to remain anonymous,
quote, because of the
sensitivity of the subject.
What this means is some
government official talked
to the reporter at the New York Times
and said, "Hey, I kind
of wanna remain anonymous
"because I'm not really
supposed to be talking
"to you about this but
I think the information
"that I'm giving you is
for the public interest
"and so I'm gonna do it anyway.
"Please don't reveal my name."
And the New York Times
is like, okay, cool.
And they publish it.
That happens every single
day all of the time.
That is one of the most
important aspects of journalism
is that a journalist can have
a source who feels protected
because they can remain anonymous
even if they talk about sensitive
or classified information.
Why?
Because in our society, we value the flow
of important information for the public
even if the government has
deemed it to be classified.
So according to the indictment
from the Department of Justice,
any New York Times article
that is quoting a government
official who's talking
about classified information,
if the New York Times
publishes that, espionage.
I mean, that's what they're saying here.
In fact tons of the leaks
that WikiLeaks published
in 2010 and 2011 were also
published by Der Spiegel
or the New York Times or the Guardian.
Oh wait, but Julian
Assange isn't a journalist.
He's not like the New York Times reporter.
Those are like technically
legitimate journalist.
No.
Journalist is not a
legally defined status.
Journalists don't enjoy
some upgraded version
of free speech.
All journalism takes place
within the free speech laws
that all of us enjoy.
Oh, and I don't really need to say this,
but those laws, those protections
are really, really important.
Free speech is what keeps
our society transparent.
It keeps our government accountable.
It is important and it is rare.
It's a new thing.
Like being able to hold
governments accountable
is like kind of a brand new
thing in human civilization.
It's not natural.
It's not guaranteed.
It can easily go away.
So, that is why I'm
concerned about this case.
Yeah, go ahead.
Charge Julian Assange with the conspiracy
to hack into a government computer.
But as soon as you
introduce the Espionage Act
into what he did, you
start to play with fire.
You're setting a precedent
that could easily be applied
to the journalism that
we rely on every day
to keep us informed
and to keep governments
and businesses accountable.
Oh, and I'm not the only
one who's concerned by this.
The Obama Administration also
worried that pursuing Assange
would be dangerous for
free speech and journalism.
So they didn't do it.
It was the Trump Administration
that really doubled down
and tried to get Assange and charge him.
And I mean, are we surprised?
So the Biden Administration
is sort of at a crossroads,
like what are they gonna do?
Are they gonna push this?
Are they gonna try to charge
Julian Assange with espionage?
Well, it turns out they
are moving ahead trying
to get him extradited to the US.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
There's been news.
We were making this video.
We were editing it just
because we're interested
in Julian Assange and
then news broke that.
- A UK judge will rule tonight
on whether WikiLeaks founder,
Julian Assange, should be
extradited to the United States
- Where a judge basically
said that it's totally legal
that Assange be sent to
the US to face trial.
- Where a Judge approved the
extradition earlier today,
- Meaning he's one step
closer to being extradited.
Now, he will probably appeal this.
It'll probably go to the
high court in the UK,
but like he's one step closer.
- How long could this drag out?
- Some time, maybe not so much time.
- My whole purpose in making
this video was not to defend
Julian Assange as a
person or even WikiLeaks
as an organization.
That's not the point.
You can make up your mind on that.
The thing that I hope
I've persuaded you though,
is that Julian Assange's
legal case has ramifications
for all of us.
If he's sent to the US and he's convicted
under the Espionage Act, that
will have major ramifications
on the future of journalism.
I hope that is clear now.
So over the coming weeks and months,
this case will play out and you know
that I will be paying attention to it.
And my hope is that you will be too.
All right, that's it.
That's all I've got for today.
This was a really deep dive.
We spent a lot of time on
this and I hope it was helpful
in some way.
So thank you all for
watching, for being here.
Lots more to come.
Hopefully videos in the
future that are not as heavy
and depressing as this one,
but this one's important.
So, glad you watched it.
Thanks for being here
and have a wonderful day.